Thank you.
Now, I'm hoping that a few more people will roll in in the next couple of minutes because I would like to make this a shorter space.
Last time, I intended to run an hour-long space, and then I wound up getting into an issue with someone who showed up.
For some reason, I'm not saying that fundamental Catholics are trolls.
I'm saying I tend to attract whatever trolls exist in the fundamentalist Catholic community.
And it's the same the same the whole time.
Sorry, every time it's the same.
But, you know, they don't announce it, right?
So even if you suspect, you know, what's going to happen, you know, I try to give people the benefit of the doubt.
And then we wind up like sort of half an hour, 45 minutes on a complete digression.
It has nothing to do with anything.
So, hey, Melissa.
So there's, and I'll repeat it if a couple more people show up, but there was a development a year or two ago involving Dean Radden, Gary Nolan, and some Noetic Sciences Institute.
I don't know if it's Institute of Noetic Sciences or Noetic Science Institute.
I'm not sure what exactly their name is.
But they did some research through 23andMe trying to find evidence for a psychic gene.
And I think their pool was kind of small, at least at first.
I'm not sure how big the final experiment was.
But what they looked at was they were looking for a mutation, a genetic mutation that would allow people to be psychic.
You know, one of the problems that one has in, like, the paranormal community is it's very heavily informed by fiction, particularly, like, comic book stuff.
But I'm not saying that, I'm not saying that that's, I'm not placing a judgment on it.
Well, I guess I am.
So the thing is, there are constantly phrases and sort of ideas and sort of infiltrate the discussions from, like, comic book and pulp fiction from the 50s through 70s.
Comic books and pulp fiction.
So one example is the whole psionics thing, right?
So psionics is a pulp science fiction term that appeared in science fiction, disappeared from science fiction.
And for the last 50 years has been pretty much only used in the role-playing community amongst people who play the game of Dungeons and Dragons.
But recently, a couple of years ago, around the same time, actually, right, a community came forward and said, no, they work for the government or they work with the government.
And the government uses the term psionics.
Now, it's the first time anyone had heard of it at that time that I could track down.
But everyone just had to accept and say, okay, they're using that term.
But the term itself came from pulp science fiction, right?
So with the psychic gene, the idea that they were looking for a mutation which gave people psychic abilities, which is what I read when I read Dean Radden's articles.
I mean, that's clearly pulp science fiction sort of comic book-y stuff.
But I guess it's a presupposition that was so deeply embedded that no one questioned it.
So, jeez, I hope Lou's going to show up because I really want him to show up.
So what happened when they went looking for the gene is they found a number of sequences which seemed to relate to families that had psychic ability, right?
Or seemed to have a psychic ability that went down through the generations.
And through a process of deduction, they identified one key genetic sequence.
But what they found when they looked at it was that rather than having a genetic sequence that indicated who would be psychic, there was a genetic mutation that indicated who wouldn't be.
So, or sorry, a genetic mutation.
So instead of a mutation allowing people to be psychic, hypothetically, a mutation was keeping certain people from being psychic.
That's the position that they came up with.
And when they looked at it, when they looked into the genetic database through 23andMe, they discovered that this gene, this mutation, about 40% of people in the system had it.
And it seems geographically clustered in the former territories of the Roman Empire.
And there's a map out there somewhere.
I have not been able to find the map since I decided to do this space, right?
So there's a map out there somewhere which shows the saturation of the gene in the local communities.
And you can see that when you look at, you know, you're looking at Europe and you see the closer you get to Rome, the more heavily expressed this mutation is until, you know, because it gets like darker and darker on the map.
So it's almost like a bullseye right on the city of Rome.
So what happened, what seems to have happened, because I remember when I first heard the research, I first saw articles about it and heard little snippets of podcasts, I said, you know, that doesn't seem like a good avenue to go down for me.
And immediately, people sort of jumped on the RH negative bandwagon.
People were, you know, talking about like red hair and RH negative.
That wasn't supported by the data at all.
It was just confabulation.
But what it was, was that areas that were where the mutation didn't seem to be present, some of them included Scotland or northern Scotland and parts of Ireland.
And the takeaway that people had was that, well, therefore, that means that Celtic DNA is more psychic or people have more psychic ability if they have Celtic DNA.
So, I don't know, it seems that some of that came from Dean Radden himself, but it seems like a complete confabulation.
It doesn't, it isn't supported by anything that they, they came up with.
And actually, this is, you know, like I said, I waited a couple of years to look into it.
And then I kept hearing this Celtic stuff and RH negative, and it just, it seemed like people were creating artificial barriers.
For the sake of like, for confirmation bias, right?
Like red haired Irish people were saying that the research proved that, you know, red haired Irish people were psychic.
That's, that was my takeaway.
So, I went to look at it.
Damn, this sucks that no one's showing up.
Because this is, I mean, this is really, isn't it amazing?
Like, the more interesting the information is, the less interested anyone is in showing up.
So, it seems as if either one of two things happened.
Either the team with Dean Radden and Gary Nolan and the Noetic Institute, or Institute of Noetic Sciences, however it's written.
Either they did not look at all into the function of this genetic sequence outside of psychic research.
Or, they did and they ignored it.
Or, I mean, a third alternative is that they did and they just didn't know what they were seeing.
I've had this conversation with a couple of intelligent people, and it seems very intuitive to me, but it didn't seem intuitive to them.
So, when I copied the genetic name, the genetic code for the mutation sequence, right?
A sequence of letters and numbers.
And when I copied that and just went and did a Google search, the non-psychic research around this genetic mutation popped up.
And completely unrelated to, you know, anything involving, like, Dean Radden or whatever.
These were, like, you know, geneticists doing research on this particular mutation.
And there's quite a bit of information on that, and very little information about the psychic gene research.
So, it turns out that this genetic mutation, its function is to suppress the ability of endogenous retroviruses
to alter the expression of human genes.
Specifically, recently acquired endogenous retroviruses.
So, from a historically recent perspective, or standpoint, recently acquired could mean thousands of years, right?
But not millions of years, right?
Thousands of years.
So, what retroviruses do, I'm sure everyone is going to know this, right?
What they do is they transfect.
They copy a little bit of themselves into human DNA.
And then those genes are inherited, and they alter the expression, or at least sometimes, right?
But when they're conserved, when they're conserved through inheritance, it's generally because they alter the expression of human genes in some way.
Which is hypothetically advantageous, right?
At least from an evolutionary standpoint.
So, the genetic mutation identified by Dean Radden as being responsible for suppressing psychic ability
is a genetic mutation that is responsible for suppressing the ability of, you know, recently acquired, from a historical perspective,
endogenous retrovirus expression altering human DNA.
So, it's very simple, right?
Like, it's not simple to say it, but it's very simple to understand it.
What it means is, it doesn't have anything to do with Rh-negative blood, red hair, the druids.
What it means is, if it's true, right?
If it's accurate, if the research is accurate.
And, again, we're just, we're looking at, like, you know, what Gary, sorry, what Dean Radden and maybe Gary Nolan,
you know, I don't know why his name was thrown in there, but, like, what Dean Radden.
We'll say, this is what Dean Radden said.
This is the genetic sequence he said was found in the research.
But the research, who knows where that is, right?
Because it's not really available to a quick search.
But we take him at his word.
So, if what he's saying is true, and the research that regular geneticists are doing about that, you know, the function of that genetic mutation,
then psychic ability would be something that is the result of historically recent acquired retroviruses, altering the expression of human genes.
It doesn't mean that Celtic people and Cherokee Indians are naturally psychic, are naturally more psychic than everyone else.
Because of their DNA, it means that, as far as we know, the function of those endogenous retroviruses in altering the expression of human DNA has not been suppressed in those populations.
So, psychic function is a retrovirus, is the result of a retrovirus, one recently acquired.
By going down that, like, okay, so, what happened was, they started to think.
And, like, why would there be this, why would there be this mutation that suppresses psychic ability?
And, of course, because in alternative paranormal circles, like it is just in vogue, to dump on Christianity.
Regardless of what each individual's feeling is.
People's personal opinions.
That is a big part of this story.
Both now and what I'm going to add to it after this.
So, the researchers sat around and they came up with the conclusion that the Spanish Inquisition, or the Inquisition in general, must be responsible for the mutation.
Because it's found primarily in the former Roman Empire and in the descendants of people from the former Roman Empire, right?
So, there are a number of, now, I'm not a geneticist, by any, you know, by any stretch of the imagination.
I don't think Dean Radden is either.
So, the first thing is, the Inquisition is a, it's not a, the popular, so, anyhow, everyone sitting in the room apparently agreed with this.
This is the consensus.
And so, it became part of the story.
And so, immediately after this information was released, the argument online, particularly at that time when, right, when the nation was largely transitioning from, at least in social media, from being a monolithic, monolithically left-wing to being, you know, more right-wing.
And I'm not political, I'm just saying that that's a transition that was happening at that time.
So, the issue became how you feel about Christianity and the persecution of Christians, and no one paid much attention to, or tried to think of it in the sense of genetics, and how long it takes for a gene to spread like that, right?
Because you don't, eliminating, because it is true, right, that there was the Inquisition, and there were also monasteries and nunneries, and odd people were sent to monasteries and nunneries.
So, there was a concerted attempt to weed out those type of traits from the population.
But that, that program was far older than the Inquisition.
So, the Inquisition itself, you know, 400 or 500 years ago, or 500, 600 years ago, around that time, right?
The Jesuits, the 1700s, the Dominicans prior to that were running the Inquisition, and Spain, 14, yeah.
So, the Inquisition itself didn't really kick off until the Spaniards kicked the Moors out in the 1400s.
So, in itself, it's like, you know, it was less than 600 years old.
You don't, you can't just eliminate the weirdos, and a mutation will naturally spread to the population, suppressing the psychic ability, or the expression of those retroviruses.
In that period of time, as far as I know.
As far as I know, and again, I'm not a geneticist, it takes, you know, thousands of years for something like that to happen.
And as I said, there was clearly a program in place.
But it stretches back prior to the Roman Catholic Church.
And, like, blaming Christianity, blaming the Roman Catholic Church, and Christians in general, right?
That is a result of their confirmation bias, right?
And it serves their personal ideology.
But I think the opposite is true.
Rather than looking at it as a result of the Inquisition, or the monastic system, the nunneries.
It could be the cause of them, right?
So, we all know that Rome and Western civilization is very different, in a lot of ways, from the rest of the world.
But particularly in the core assumptions.
There's been a ton of, like, sociological and psychological research about this.
You know, I remember in high school, they taught us, if you show pictures, or you have people read a story, depending on where they're from in the world, they'll see, they'll look at the picture, the painting of the picture, and they'll see different things.
For instance, a strongly Western perspective would be to look at the very dead center of the picture.
And describe everything that's happening from the perspective of whatever is in the middle of the picture.
Whereas, we were taught, you know, who knows?
It was the 90s, so God only knows.
That in other cultures, they will often start with the peripheral, what we would consider to be peripheral data.
And that's the story to them, right?
As opposed to looking at it from the central perspective of whatever individual or thing is located at the very center of the picture.
The ultramaterialism.
I mean, it's hard for me to imagine, because I don't have that problem.
Like, I don't, I'm not a professional psychic, but I'm not, I definitely don't have that mutation.
So, throughout my life, and this is going someplace.
So, you know, I've always run into people who will swear up and down, like, we don't know what's going to happen.
And it's almost like a religion to them.
And when we're talking about geopolitical events, when we're talking about regional events, when we're talking about events in the family,
when we're talking about cause and effect, the weather the next day, right?
Like, there are people who are, like, doggedly adamant that we have no way at all of knowing what's going to happen.
And then as the rest of us, we're like, yeah, well, we do, actually.
We're not 100% right, but we generally know what's going to happen, you know, a while before it happens.
So, to that 40%, those 40% of people, it would naturally follow that if they have no psychic ability whatsoever, they have no foresight.
And I remember talking to a very famous astrologer about this, and talking about how, at that time, the conversation, or my post was about how psychopaths have no foresight.
And she was very strongly arguing with me that it's not true.
That she knows psychopaths, and they are able to predict the future very well.
And, like, at that time, I was unable to articulate the difference between what she was saying and what I was saying.
But I think that, had I known what I know now then, I would have said, you know, they have no psychic ability.
They have no psychic foresight, right?
No psychic intuition.
So, the lack of psychic intuition, and when you look at the maps, right, like, the mutation seems to have originated, like, very close to the city of Rome itself, if not in the city of Rome itself, geographically.
So, everything that differentiated Rome and the West from the time of Rome could largely be explained by the high percentage of this mutation in the population.
The high percentage of individuals who lack psychic ability completely.
So, when you talk about genetics, when you look at, it's called integration, right?
So, when you have a population, the population, like, the smaller population, their genetic traits will be disproportionately represented in the population in general.
So, 10% or 20% of a population can completely change the culture, the society, and the genetics of that population.
Because their traits will be significantly overrepresented.
The same thing would be true.
It's always true.
So, the same thing would be true with this hyper-materialism as time went on, like, this spreading population who didn't have any psychic ability.
If we look back, right, this is where I'm going.
So, this really explains what was going on with Gnosticism.
It really explains the events of the beginning of antiquity, at the beginning of the Christian period.
It's sort of like a master key.
And it may not seem like it at first, but it's actually really huge.
Because so many of the things that, like, we discuss, right, focus on this, like, what is the difference between, you know, materialist people and spiritual people?
What's the difference?
And also, what's the difference of the area, like, the Roman Empire, right?
The West is still the Roman Empire, right?
It's no longer politically the Roman Empire, but the cultures that were based off the Roman culture that went on to dominate the world, they were the colonialist powers.
Like, when you talk about the colonialist powers, you talk about nations that were formerly part of the Roman Empire.
So, when we look back to how this started, and this is where it gets kind of, that's why I'm hemming and hawing, because I'm kind of hoping that people would show up before I just launch into this.
But I guess no one's going to show up.
And, you know, I think Lou told me it was going to come, so I'm really disappointed.
So, I'm going to try to compact the rest of this into half an hour.
In Gnosticism, right, the universe is created in the source, aeons are emanated, spiritual beings, we would call them beings of light, or they may be the personification of universal principles.
We're emanated through this sort of chain of creation, one of them, Sophia, wants to create on her own, and she creates this, this mistake, called the Demiurge.
And the Demiurge goes on to create the universe, and the bodies that human beings live in, that trap the spirits.
Who's that?
Oh, Stephanie, this is, I'm glad you're here.
Thank you, but, um, this, this, I don't know if I can come back, this may be too crazy, um, from where I'm at right now.
Uh, but I'll, I'll try.
So, the, the Gnostic tale of creation is the, is the Old Testament tale of creation told from a different perspective.
Uh, people don't recognize that, because a lot of people who study, who get very religious, um,
not everyone, and, you know, but a lot of people get very religious, have, um, have a difficulty with, with metaphorical, um, literature.
Uh, and discerning what is metaphorical, and what is literal in ancient texts, and not, you know, there are very, a lot of very intelligent, super religious people, right?
But, um, um, but, um, a lot of times, the popular, oh, there she goes.
Bye, Stephanie.
The popular translation, uh, or the popular, um, uh, the, the popular reading of religious texts is sort of negative perfectionist,
and, um, their interpretations are targeted to be understood by people who aren't that bright.
You know, 30% of Americans believe if you take, uh, um, six ounces of orange juice in a 12-ounce glass and pour it into an 8-ounce glass,
so it now looks like the glass is more full.
30% of Americans, um, will answer in tests that there is now, in fact, more orange juice.
The act of pouring the orange juice half of a tall glass into a short glass creates more orange juice.
That, like, that's a good anecdote to give an idea of, like, why, um, when you're creating explanations,
and you have to gear them to be understood by everyone, um, often they're not the best explanations.
So, uh, the Gnostic tale is not, like, there's all this nonsense now that I don't really know anything about
that people spring on me when the subject of Gnosticism comes up,
and I'm, I'm getting involved in these Strauman arguments because none of it is really anything that existed in antiquity.
It's all modern pop, um, I don't know, weirdness, modern pop occultism that just, um, people appropriate ancient terms.
Uh, but, you know, Sophia is Eve, right?
And, um, told from a different perspective.
So, from, from this perspective, right, prior to the fall, um, Adam and Eve were beings of light.
And, um, as opposed to being, um, as a, okay, so the demiurge is DNA.
And I mean, I could do a whole, I have done a space talking about that, right?
And I could, I could ramble on, um, and, and continue to be not very focused.
Um, so I'm just going to put it out there and say, look, you have to kind of just imagine that you agree with that.
So that's what the, the demiurge is, right?
And there's a great book called The Cosmic Gene, um, that was put out in the 90s that, that made the case very well.
Um, Sophia, whatever Sophia, whatever wisdom is, was connected to the chain of creation for DNA.
The, the universe is, um, the apparent universe, right?
Which is an apparent universe of moving forms, um, because, you know, we all seem to be independent, uh, bodies, beings.
But in fact, we're all, uh, manifestations of the same, um, thing, this DNA, right?
So we assume that all life must have DNA in it, but that may not be a valid assumption.
And, uh, I mean, all complex life.
And in a sense, um, we are what the guy found, the author found, was these, these old stories and these stories coming out of Aboriginal communities,
you know, look at us as being sort of, uh, a disguise for DNA, right?
Like, uh, puppets, puppets managed by this, um, this greater intelligence, which is, uh, the serpent of, of DNA.
And there's, he filled up a whole book on anecdotes and, and, and reasons to accept this explanation.
So, uh, so after seeing the universe created by the Demiurge, uh, Sophia got trapped in it.
And because of the personification issues, we, we wind up with, like, um, Chris Bledsoe and modern people trying to appropriate this story and, and talk about, like, uh, the lady.
This image that people see and associate it with Sophia, but Sophia is, is wisdom, the embodiment of wisdom.
And it seems as if something metaphorically, like, very, very well described metaphorically by the, the story happened.
It seems as if, um, this, there was a virus, a retrovirus that, um, that gave us this, uh, this wisdom, this, um, this, this foresight.
Right.
Um, this is a tough one to bring together.
So all of this speculation that, that we talk about, it's coming out of the remote viewing community today or not coming out of the remote viewing community today because they're suppressing it.
Right.
Uh, it focuses around the idea that the, the world is in some way artificial.
And it traces this information back to the, the ancient Gnostics, back to the, um, ancient Indians, uh, or modern Indians too, back to, um, the, the, the Buddhists, right?
Like all the ancient, ancient Greeks also had this story.
Uh, the, the world is artificial.
It's an illusion.
But we don't know what happened prior to the illusion, right?
So the idea is if, if, if we accept that, like both modern clairvoyance and ancient clairvoyance and ancient cultures, and everyone up until recently had the idea that the world was an illusion.
Um, as a matter of fact, everyone except for the people who are descended from the area where this gene, uh, mutation, uh, interferes with people's psychic ability.
Right.
Everywhere else has this idea that the world is, is in some way, um, an illusion, some aspect of it.
There's a reality overlay, um, that isn't real.
Um, um, I think we, we, so we don't know, right?
And so we've had arguments, um, with people who, uh, when would this have happened?
And I think there's an assumption that it would have happened like in ancient, ancient times.
But I have, I have harbored the suspicion that that may not be true.
And the reason is everything we know about this stuff, right?
Um, when we talk about simulations, computer simulations, reality overlays, uh, the science fiction, you know, psychic stuff and how that intersects with this, right?
It all goes back to the pulp science fiction writing of an author named Philip K. Dick.
It does.
And, um, he wrote, you know, Total Recall.
He wrote, um, or the book that became Total Recall, right?
He wrote, uh, the, the story that became Blade Runner.
Most of the really popular, but somewhat offbeat, um, modern science fiction movies are from stories written by, uh, Philip K. Dick.
And he started having these dreams.
He couldn't, he couldn't, um, he couldn't stop himself from having these dreams.
He had to write these stories.
He started writing the stories.
Um, and then 1974, he had this experience when he was high on dental anesthesia.
And, um, he had this like crazy, um, awakening experience.
And, uh, you know, people thought that he had turned into a schizophrenic because of all his drug use.
And he said that, uh, he introduced all the ideas that we're talking about.
All right.
Like, uh, the Mandela effect.
Um, he didn't use the Mandela effect as the term, right?
But he, he was talking about that in the 1970s.
He was talking about the simulation.
He was talking about the psychic stuff.
He was everything that's found in the, um, in the remote viewing material.
Um, I'm going to write this into an article because I'm not doing a good job of expressing it, but I'm going to keep plowing through until this is done.
Um, I think part of it is that I'm upset that I'm, that I'm upset that Lou and a couple other people who would have had a personal interest in this aren't here.
So his big thing, Philip K. Dick, his big thing was the, the empire never ended.
And he said a lot of different stuff.
Like his, his journals were 8,000 pages.
And I think they sell a 700 page version, but they, you know, just cut out like the most interesting 700 pages.
So there's a lot of contradiction there, but it seems that at different points, his perspective was that this is some sort of simulation.
This is a prison, you know, a, a, uh, prison reality.
Um, but the prison reality itself was created for early Christians.
That was his idea.
Gnostic Christians weren't just people came up with these ideas.
They were the original, um, they were the original inmates of this reality prison.
And moreover, he believed that once you start accepting, right.
The, not, not this is not what he said.
Once you start accepting the idea that there may be something artificial about reality.
And again, this is just a thought exercise.
Uh, you come to the conclusion that time itself, right.
Um, doesn't make much sense.
If we're being reincarnated or whatever these ancient people said, um, and there's something illusional about the reality, then time is part of that illusional reality.
So, uh, what Phil K. Dick was saying, and this is also what, um, the Gnostics were saying.
And it's also what the remote viewers say now, right.
Is that the, the individuals in question, the, the inmates are the same inmates.
So they're reincarnating in the reality overlay.
They're not reincarnating outside the reality overlay, right.
So from Phil K. Dick's perspective, the people who were trapped in this reality were the apostles.
He, he very strongly believed that the original Christian church were the ones who were placed into the, well, you know, prison reality.
The, the, the, the black iron prison is what he called it.
And that in, while we perceive there being a history and we perceive there being, you know, this, um, um, um, we perceive time being linear, right.
In fact, we're still in ancient Rome and in prison there, right.
Like if, if, uh, if we're looking at like the matrix, okay.
Um, instead of the pods being created in, you know, 2100, the pods would have been created in, you know, 300.
Um, or 50, 75, 80.
Like that from Phil K. Dick's perspective, that is when the, the, um, the simulation began.
Well, no, what's super interesting about that is, um, when this, these ideas started to spread, right.
Cause Phil K. Dick was, um, sort of the originator of all the alternative thought, um, that went on to form.
The, um, San Francisco Bay Area version of new age ism.
So Terrence McKenna and, uh, Robert Anton Wilson, um, like those individuals, they were highly informed or inspired by Phil K. Dick and his work.
And.
They all embraced this idea in the sixties and seventies without crediting him directly.
So this, you know, in, um, by the time the eighties rolled around and they were, they were giving interviews or when we look at like some of the oldest recordings of them from the eighties and nineties that are still available online.
So they make that argument, the argument they make is that we are, you know, they, they, they get involved in the multiple realities, uh, which is a specious argument, but, but, you know, this isn't, I don't, I will really be rambling if I try to explain that one.
Uh, what they say is, uh, the reason that our reality turned out the way it did is because we had Christians and the other realities are very different because they didn't.
So, um, the main branch for this multiple reality, right.
Um, would be that the Romans didn't persecute the Christians, um, that the Christians wound up taking control of Rome.
And this is a historical argument as well.
There's, um, a historical argument.
The Romans were on the edge of an industrial revolution, right?
So that's, that's not a fringe argument.
That's a little bit fringe, but it is something that, that does exist in, in the, the field of history.
The idea that, and there's this, some strong evidence, by the way, even if you're looking at it from materials standpoint, the Romans were sort of right on the edge of the industrial revolution and the events that occurred, um, during the period following the advent of Christianity and the fall of Rome.
Um, um, those events obviously forestalled that industrial revolution, but had those events been different and the Romans, um, developed the, you know, gone through the industrial revolution, uh, 1500 years earlier or 2000 years early, earlier than, than the rest of the world did.
Then, you know, their world would have ended up looking kind of like ours merged with Rome.
And, uh, the argument people make is that that's what the other realities are.
And we're specifically different because of the Christianity.
So what Philip K. Dick would have said was, no, we're different because this is, um, a prison for the Christians.
Right.
And so then, and again, he was labeled as a schizophrenic, but that's what he's, this is his, his belief in his, he was never diagnosed.
I don't think, but he was labeled by people as a schizophrenic.
So this is his, his belief.
This is what he wrote in his exegesis, his journals.
Um, this is what he wrote in his books and this is what was coming out of his subconscious in his literature prior to him having that awakening experience.
Right.
This is the central theme, um, was that this is not the real reality and that the real reality, um, the empire never ended.
And in fact, we're probably still in antiquity, right?
That, that the, the, the time period between antiquity now only existed inside of a simulation.
Um, I'm not saying it's true, but it's very interesting when you look at the, the remote viewers.
And when you look at the, um, ancient Gnostic texts and the belief of the, the Buddhists and the beliefs of the Hindus and the beliefs of the Mesoamericans, right?
And the beliefs of the ancient Greeks that were in this artificial reality.
But up until now, we didn't have any physical mark on what is the Roman empire.
Right.
The Roman empire visibly is gone.
So they say, well, the Roman empire became the Catholic church.
Okay.
That's true.
And then it became the 10 nations or so that make up the area of the former Roman empire.
Okay.
That's true.
Um, and if you look at it like that, uh, you could look at the, the, um, geopolitics of the West and, um, you could look at Gibbon's decline and fall of the Roman empire.
Right.
We, we have the same, uh, geopolitical strategy in the same places.
We build bases in the same places.
We build the same type of bases.
Like we're, there's, uh, an extreme continuity between Roman culture, Roman thought, Roman strategy, and Roman geography, um, with the modern world that most people aren't aware of.
Right.
Okay.
So if we could trace psychic ability back to these retroviruses, not specific ones, but the existence of, of retroviruses at a certain period of time.
Then we opened the door to talk about like the extraterrestrial hypothesis, right?
Um, ancient alien shit because retroviruses are a vector for, or can be a vector for genetic engineering.
Now, from the perspective I'm looking at it, this is largely metaphorical, um, because from our perspective, things are, you know, literally real, they're tangible, but they're also metaphorical because the, the world exists within the collective unconscious.
Right.
But this is the, the marker because you can now look at a genetic map of this mutation and you can see that, you know, this mutation is, is, is, is basically, um, located in the, in this geographic area.
It's the same, the, the previous borders of the Roman empire and this, this mutation.
Now, when you get to like the new world, things are a little different.
And the reason things are a little different is we all know that in, you know, once you get out of the major cities in Europe, um, you know, people tend to be descended from the same people who lived there like thousands of years ago.
Um, the same bloodlines have stayed in the same, in the same area, like within miles.
Right.
I mean, they found like the oldest preserved bog man and they found the guy who was like genetically closest to him and it was like 9,000 years apart.
He looked exactly identical to the drawing.
They hype it made of the hypothetical appearance of that guy.
And he lived three miles from where the body was found.
So that's the difference between the U S and in Europe, we would have recessive, right.
In, because of the genetic admixture in the new world, um, the gene would be showing up in strange places.
Um, so you could have, you know, I, I have ancestors who come from those nations inside the Roman empire and I have ancestors who come from the area that was identified as being, uh, more psychic.
Cause they don't have this, um, they don't have that mutation.
So in my family, I have like close relatives in my family who don't have any foresight or psychic ability at all.
They don't believe it.
They don't have any belief at all in anything paranormal, divine or anything else, because they, they lack that capacity to even perceive that as being real.
I mean, I mean, I have a brother, I have a brother, you know, the closest person to me genetically in the, in the world.
And he has never had a perception like that in his life.
He doesn't believe it's real.
And he believes that anyone who has those perceptions is crazy.
Now that's 60% of the population, but they do because they are not only incapable of, of having that sense, right.
They don't, not only do they lack extrasensory perception, they lack the ability to perceive extrasensory perception.
So when other people are experiencing it, all they perceive as someone who's nuts.
Okay.
Even if that's 60% of the world and you know, our, our politicians, but you know, more important than our politicians, our law enforcement officers, but more important than that, our scientists and our doctors.
I'm willing to bet, I mean, this is, this is a speculation, but I'm willing to bet my speculation will be confirmed that the majority of accomplished scientists and doctors have that mutation.
I think that's probably part of, um, part of how they get interested in those fields and part of how they become very successful.
So I think that when we talk about the people who are defining what is sane and isn't sane and what is real and what isn't real, because we have those roles in our society, by and large, I think those individuals are incapable of any type of psychic perception at all.
And to the extent that they don't even believe it's real, and they can't, they can't believe it's real, right?
So we now have that, and we have that, we can, we can locate that geographically in the, in the former Roman Empire.
So what is the Roman Empire?
Is it a place?
Is it a, is it a people?
Because the people broke up, right?
Is it a church?
Or is it a genetic mutation, right?
Are we not, is it, is it a mentality?
Because the effects of this, um, mutation are neurological.
And they're, they're, they're looking at that, not from the psychic perspective, uh, but they're looking at that in the actual, uh, the other genetic research as well.
Right?
So there is a, a mentality resulting from a genetic mutation that characterizes both the population of the area, the former Roman Empire and the mentality of the culture and societies and individuals from that area.
Of which the United States is one, right?
Because even though we're in the new world, our, our society has always been dominated by, um, the descendants of, of the nations that came out of the Roman Empire, right?
Because England was one of those nations.
Now, the, the gene is less expressed in England than it is in Italy, but it's definitely there.
And that's where they came up with the idea that like this evidence in some way vindicated Celtic psychic ability.
Because there's a very distinct line, right?
Separating England, um, and, and Northern Ireland from Ireland and Scotland, but particularly Scotland, right?
There's, there's more Anglo blood in Ireland, probably than Northern Scotland.
Um, so this vindicates, this is a vindication of the concepts that Philip K. Dick was trying to talk about.
He was drawing out of his, his unconscious.
He was drawing into his art and he was laboring to explain to people at a time when there was no vocabulary other than science fiction.
Right?
So he was attempting to tell them these things and they were just responding by saying he was, who's crazy.
But the storyline got adopted.
The storyline that what, what makes our world different from any other possible hypothetical utopia was the presence of Christians.
Now, when you get into the, set aside the reality or, or, uh, non-reality of linear time, right?
When we get into the, um, the genetics of the inquisition and the monastic system, right?
That, that, that were present in, in Europe going all the way back, I think to about when all this went down, I think St. Benedict, uh, got rolling before, uh, Constantine, um, made the, the Catholic church, the de facto.
And we know there were Christian desert fathers prior to that.
So there was, uh, an early movement and that movement was also internal to Christianity, by the way.
Like you were supposed to separate yourself from the world.
So it wasn't like just an external force, um, applying itself to suppress psychic ability.
Um, it was also a movement that was trying to separate itself from, um, the rest of society.
We don't think of that today because we're 2000 years away from that.
So when we talk about Christianity today, we are not talking about, um, the early Christian movement at all.
And they were very strongly, um, they, they were very strongly committed to separating as much as possible, uh, from the rest of Roman society.
And that's where a lot of the persecution came from.
Not that there wouldn't have been persecution anyways, but that was the justification, largest speaking.
Right.
I mean, they were called, um, remember the early Christians were accused of, uh, for hundreds of years were accused of being atheists because they didn't practice the Roman state religion.
The Roman state religion wasn't even like the Catholicism of today.
Right.
At that time, the, the priests and the temples were largely like, um, they're almost like clubs.
They're almost like the, um, the, uh, the Elks or the Freemasons.
Not that I'm drawing it to any crazy conspiracy.
What I'm saying is, uh, like local officials were also the local priests, right?
And being a priest of the local shrine was part of their duties as being the official.
So like your, your town selectmen would also be the high priests of the local cult.
It was a civic function, right?
And so the, the sacred religious function that we, we project on the past, like that, that wasn't as strong at that time.
And the further you go back, the less sacred religion was and the more functional it was, the more performative it was.
Um, and if you get all the way back to like ancient Egypt or Babylon, it was basically like the local welfare office, except they did marriages.
Um, largely record keeping some banking, um, distributing welfare.
Like if you look back at their, at their ancient texts, you know, in tablet form, or, uh, they, they spend very little time actually talking about what we would consider to be a religion.
Now it's, it's all about the social functions of the temple.
So, um, when the Christians, after Christianity, Orthodox Christianity took over, took over the Roman Empire, right?
Like when those persecutions began, the individuals they were focused on persecuting weren't pagans.
Now there were pagan persecutions, there were, but the, like a modern sort of sixties liberal, um, their, their imagination of what the past was like.
Um, everyone was sort of a witch, right?
Like, like everyone was kind of a witch.
Um, and that's what paganism was.
And, uh, and then Christianity invaded, um, and destroyed, you know, just killed everyone, slaughtered everyone.
That's not what, I mean, if you've even, if you even studied like religion in high school, um, or the history of religion in high school, like incidentally to world history, you know, that wasn't true.
Uh, mostly the, the churches were built on the, you know, the same spots as the old churches, right?
The gods were converted into saints.
Um, so it was more of a transitional process than it was this annihilation.
And if there had been this annihilation, you'd be able to see it in the genes beyond just the mutation that we're talking about, right?
You would see, uh, when you look at France, Belgium, Germany, or England, um, and you take their genetics, they're very similar to the clearly descended from the indigenous people of those areas, right?
Like a modern English person has the vast majority of the genetics are those of an ancient English person.
If the Roman empire came in and just annihilated everyone or replaced everyone, then everyone would be Italian genetically, right?
But we're not.
So that's nonsense.
The majority of the crusades and inquisitions and persecutions were of, um, were less of paganism and witchcraft, although that, that became bigger as time went on.
And I'm sure it was always there, but, you know, most of these crusades, internal crusades in Europe, right?
Um, and persecutions were of other Christian sects.
Now, you can make the argument, they weren't Christian sects, they were heretical.
That opens like a giant can of worms.
It's not accurate.
Um, they weren't, uh, alien cults from another land.
They were indigenous.
They were there from the very beginning as a part of Christianity.
They, they spread off, they, they, they broke off.
Now, you can, you can denigrate them, but definitely the majority of these persecutions, right?
The Cal, the Cathars, the Bogomils, the Albacinians, the, the ones where millions of people were being killed, right?
When, when the inquisition was hunting for, in, in Spain, okay, they were mostly looking for Jews.
And I'm not saying that to be offensive to Jews.
I'm saying that's mostly what they were looking for, right?
There were also witch hunts.
And they were looking for Muslims who were hiding, um, being Muslim.
Like, so they were looking for religious dissenters, but they weren't looking for, like, you know, it wasn't like there was this huge underground faith community who were all Wiccans.
That's some, some modern creation.
Uh, they were people who believed themselves to be Christians who had different beliefs about what it meant to be Christian.
So, uh, when they say this number, like, well, 8 million witches were killed, that's not, that's not accurate.
Um, it's, the, the number isn't accurate, but contained within that number, they're talking about people like the Cathars.
The Cathars were Christians.
The Cathars practiced ancient Christianity, right?
Ancient, uh, an ancient version of Christianity.
The Bogomils, the Alvis Indians, those were all people practicing Christianity.
So the majority of people that were persecuted were also, were these other Christian faiths, which may be categorized as Gnostic.
And people often say that.
And if it's true, then the majority of the persecution was against Gnostics, but they weren't pagans.
Okay.
Um, they weren't like hedge witches and shit.
So when this, um,
when they were rounding up the psychics, basically, right, which is what Dean Radden is saying must have happened in order to, uh, create a situation where in the former Roman empire, a mutation is, is common.
That, um, that, um, that, um, blocked psychic ability.
When they were, um, rounding up the psychics, the majority of those psychics, we can assume, you know, weren't just like, um, the wise woman, right?
They were the practitioners of these other Christian faiths that happened to incorporate clairvoyance into their faith.
So it's a, it's a, it's a more complicated picture than what they would like to, what the, what they call the quote, the consensus is.
Um, and they really, like this really very important information just got dumped because, you know, they have a personal bias against Christianity, which caused them to, to explain it in such a way that led to the reaction from other people being, well, this is, this is Christian persecution, right?
Because this guy's saying that, you know, um, the reason that 40% of the human race isn't psychic is because the Christians killed everyone, um, killed off all the witches.
And that's not true, but it is true, or it seems to be true if what they're saying is correct.
If they're, if they're right about in their, in their study, then it definitely seems to be true that the reason that 40% of the human race isn't psychic is because of Rome.
And, um, a mutation to block, to block that, um, the expression of the retroviruses that led to human psychic ability in the beginning.
So we can look at this metaphorically and say the retroviruses are the divine invasion from Philokitek.
The retroviruses are fallen Sophia hiding in the world, right?
That would be like, call it the Sophia virus, call it the Adam and Eve virus, call it the, uh, the Gnostic virus.
There was a, there was a retrovirus at some point, one or more, um, you know, probably within the last 10,000 years that, and I'm, I'm just spitballing there, right?
Cause I'm not a geneticist, but definitely it's recent.
And so we're talking about within the history of civilization that led to this, um, led to this, uh, psychic, um, not revolution.
Everything's a revolution now, right?
Led to, um, changing the expression of human genes so that people had psychic ability.
Um, that, that would be something that happened like probably after civilization began.
And it probably is why the way people think changes over time right now that's speculation, but I think it's, it's warranted speculation that the reason that the way people think changes, um, as civilization progresses is because of the, the foresight.
That having access to psychic ability gives people, that's an opinion.
There was, um, in 2011, um, like this, um, this story popped up in alternative media in 2011 that said that in the late nineties, early two thousands, a mainframe computer located someplace in Africa, which is kind of odd.
I mean, I guess they, they have mainframe computers, but.
It's sort of an odd, it doesn't really tell us where in Africa.
I don't think I have to go back and look.
It's called the, it's called the Channing project, um, C-H-A-N-I.
And it claimed, um, that, uh, beings from another dimension, human beings from another dimension were trying to communicate through this mainframe computer or had communicated this mainframe computer.
And they told the one that I'm saying was coming out of the work of Philip K.
Dick and also sort of came out of the, like San Francisco, uh, new age alternative community in the, in the seventies.
Well, it, it apparently, the claim was that there was this, um, non-human intelligence or human intelligence from another dimension that contacted scientists through this mainframe computer.
Um, and the story it told was identical that they're the different, they were Roman.
They were, um, another dimension where the Romans, um, dominated.
And it was, it's, it's, it's very fanciful science fiction because they like, they talk about blowing up the moon, right?
They talk about like fighting reptilians and shit.
Like, um, the, allegedly the story is like, you know, we already fought our reptilians and we had to blow up the moon and very fanciful science fiction.
Um, but it's another version of that story sort of coming out of nowhere.
So this story is sort of bubbled up all over the place in modern remote viewing.
Um, sometimes when remote viewers view the simulation, uh, they will get to the word Terra, T E R R A.
And one of the ways that a person can remote view, uh, prior to the simulation, let's say if it's accurate, right?
If they're hitting the target, but if you, if what people are doing is, is, is real, if, if, if they're accurately hitting the target,
then the way that one would remote view prior to the simulation, um, would be to remote view prior to earth.
Now the, you know, the word earth obviously is, it's only like 500 years old, right?
I think it goes back to the F 1400.
So in the ancient times, um, you know, they didn't call it earth.
They called the planet Terra or Gaia.
Although Gaia was more of a goddess.
So what I noticed prior to, um, having this conversation with Morgan some, some time ago, uh, was that at least in one case, and I think it was several, the word Terra had come up in these remote viewing sessions about, um, the simulation.
And the remote viewers didn't know they were viewing the simulation.
And there are also people who don't have, like, if you know, many remote viewers, uh, they, they don't generally have many interests.
They don't know much.
And I'm not saying that to be offensive to them.
I'm saying like, when they get heavily into remote viewing, they stop, uh, pursuing other interests.
Because if they intend to be professional remote viewers, uh, the more they know, um, the more that can taint their sessions.
So they stop pursuing knowledge, uh, alternative knowledge, um, that might come up in their, in their sessions.
Um, and there may also be just a natural, like the personality type that a person who becomes really interested in remote viewing isn't super interested in these other ideas and theories, but definitely it's a conscious decision at some point to stop.
Um, and not like they don't watch each other's videos.
They don't, uh, follow each other's work very closely.
Um, they don't watch video.
I mean, in general, like, I don't know a row of viewers who spend much time watching YouTube videos.
Um, so to have them bring up this, this concept, Terra, also Christianity has come up in at least one remote viewers, um, one remote viewers simulation work in a very similar way to what Philip K. Dick was saying.
I don't know if it's coming up in others.
I, I, there's other RV project work around Christianity.
I think that, that is supportive of this idea.
However, for me, that's a big red line.
I don't, I would never pursue or want to encourage the replacing basic Christian theology with ideas that people come up with in remote viewing sessions.
It's just, it's not that accurate.
Um, you know, you never know if you, if they're off target and it just, it just wouldn't be a good idea.
It's just, in my opinion, right.
Our role viewing is never going to replace Christianity or the central tenants of Christianity, in my opinion.
So I, I, I look at that work differently and I don't incorporate it, uh, specifically in the, um, the simulation theory.
Um, like when I do spaces on simulation theory, I, I don't, I don't get into that too, too closely.
I can say that if anyone, I'm sure at least a few people here and a few people who will listen later, um, are familiar with like UFO experience or culture.
And what you find when you look into the history of UFO or paranormal experience or culture is that Christian themes are disproportionately represented that are edited out later.
So if you look at like UFO experiences, um, sometimes there's Christian imagery involved that, that is edited out and historical, um, when people say like when they write books about the, um, the history of UFO encounters, some of them edit out the, the correlating Christian imagery.
That appeared at the same time, some don't, some don't, a good one is, um, the gods of Eden by William Bramley, right?
Um, but it was always there.
So Christian imagery were, was always, um, closely related to what we now consider to be UFO stuff, um, historically.
And at least in my day, right in the nineties, prior to that, um, there had been a lot of Christian imagery involved in.
Um, a lot of the UFO cases that had been edited out.
My opinion has always been that there's a, uh, uh, that while we are in a reality overlay, like it's the Christian themes, imagery and the Christian faith is very tightly wound into what's going on.
So, you know, back to Philip K. Dick, who said basically that as part of the persecution of Christians, the, you know, that, that's why the simulation was created in his opinion.
Again, right.
In his time, he didn't have anyone who thought anything remotely close to what he was thinking.
And although he was never diagnosed as a schizophrenic, right?
Like that's how people approached a lot of what he, what he said.
So, um, you know, um, I'm only pointing out that he was the originator of a lot of these ideas.
And, um, that was, you know, that is often edited from his story that he believed that the black iron prison was a prison for, uh, Christian apostles.
Right.
Created by the Romans.
When, when I was first talking to, um, or not first, but a while ago, um, when I was actively talking to Morgan, you know, when I would look at what they wrote about, or when I was talking to them about what they wrote about, like, base reality.
And, um, um, the world prior to, or outside of the reality overlay.
Again, these are, these are descriptive terms people using to describe something they don't fully understand.
There's a science fiction element to it.
Um, this isn't a, um, you know, I'm not saying this is, this is literally real in the way that I'm saying it.
I'm saying it's consistently related historically, and that's meaningful.
Um, their conception was that prior to this, uh, there was a war.
And after that war, um, some political prisoners were, were put into the reality overlay was created as a part of a series of unethical experiments on political prisoners.
Um, but that, uh, most everyone on the planet, um, was dead at that time.
That's something they've been adamant about that.
And if you row view base level reality, you don't see people.
I don't know if, um, I've always been skeptical about that because I, I don't think there's been a remote viewing, uh, mapping.
I don't think there's been a learning of all of base level reality based on this session work.
Um, but that's a feeling that the remote viewers have.
I think that, uh, my, my intuition is that if they spent more time looking into that concept, um, they would say that, uh, base level reality was sparsely populated.
Um, but, um, just the presence of this experiment that they're, you know, this unethical experiment that they're looking at indicates that there are people.
I think that they look at those individuals as some form of NHI.
Um, and I'm skeptical about that.
And from the very beginning, I have said this, this all seems very Roman.
So that's just the personal feeling.
Um, I think that the, the consensus in the RV community of people who look into the simulation and think about it.
And again, this is complete speculation on my part, right?
I, I'm not in that position to say this authoritatively, but my feeling is, um, that they look at it as something involving non-human intelligence, Anunnaki type stuff.
I don't, I don't necessarily think that's accurate.
Um, and I don't know if anyone has ever looked into the question very closely.
I think that they do very superficial targeting around like is reality a simulation, not, um, they don't look very deeply into, um, how it would work if it was right.
Like they don't, they don't follow up with like, well, let's look at, um, let's look at the different continents at, you know, in base level reality, et cetera.
All right.
They, they all see this building temple of the moon cathedral, like building, and the experiments are being done in the basement to a giant cathedral, like building, um, cathedral, like interestingly enough, that's often related.
It's also called, it's also described as a pagoda, right?
So pagoda, like, and cathedral, like with this massive underground structure where these experiments are supposed to taking place, right?
And, um, up until, right, up until I Googled that, um, mutation, this was all disparate science fiction.
It was all disparate, clairvoyant communities.
The, um, the stories that they would tell, right?
The stories that they would tell about the perception they made.
Um, going back to antiquity, going back to the, you know, um, original Christian Gnostics.
They consider themselves Christians.
People now call them Gnostics.
They were given that term as a, as a way of othering them.
Um, so we could get into like circular discussions about what they should really be called, but they were there.
And, um, we know exactly how their organizational structure worked at that time, um, because we have a document.
We have documents, we have books, right?
And so we know that they, that original, um, prior to the ascension of orthodoxy, that the majority of the, of the people who identified with the Christian movement, right?
In the very beginning, um, they, they didn't have, right, uh, the type of church structure that we have now.
Um, they had wandering evangelists.
They didn't call them evangelists.
We call them evangelists now.
They call them prophets.
Okay.
And once you recognize that, uh, it's easy to connect them with the religious movements in Israel at the time.
So as long as you sort of superimpose the, um, the modern organization of the Christian church on the very original Christians, where you can't find that.
And so you have to confabulate and invent sort of like, uh, something that we don't have much evidence for.
And then they don't fit well with the Jewish community, right?
So how did they go from the Jewish community and the structure we know that nonconformist religious groups had in the Jewish community to the structure that we have today, like deacons and priests or ministers and bishops.
And like, how did we make that leap, right?
Um, and when did that come in?
It was a 200 years after the death of Jesus or, um, because you can say, well, you know, Peter was the Bishop of Rome, but there were no priests at that time.
So that's the missing link.
The missing link was that the, well, who we look at is the wandering evangelists who were seen as wandering prophets, just as they were in Israel.
Um, and so that's the connection between the old Testament and new Testament Christianity are the prophets, right?
Who we know that they were wandering around leading communities, uh, four or 500 years before Christ.
And it seems that that was what they were doing in the early Roman empire as well.
And then when Orthodoxy took over, it transitioned into this, um, um, the, the, the, the prophets stopped moving around.
Right.
And they became priests at some point of like a local congregation as opposed to moving around.
So in there, in the guidelines that we have, like they weren't supposed to stay in the same house more than two or three days like that.
They were like, when the evangelists were moving, they were moving, going from home to home.
They weren't like going to a city and then, you know, renting an apartment there and staying there for six months.
Like they were, you know, going from house to house until there were no more houses to stay.
And then they left and went to another town.
And that's sort of how it, how it worked, which is very similar to the Cather, um, organization.
But I, I'm digressing by going down that, that rabbit hole.
Those same structures were structures that were persecuted by the, the Orthodox church.
Once it, once the, once Orthodox Christianity took over, Catholicism and Orthodoxy were called Orthodox Christianity, or we refer to it as Orthodox Christianity.
Uh, once that took over, right.
That those structures were persecuted as being rural or, um, you know, as being the, um, what the hell was the term?
Uh, there was a, there was a, there were terms, um, that was right around the time that, uh,
people like writers like Philip K. Dick, um, and historical documents would show that that, that's right around the nexus of when this event may have happened.
Other esoteric schools say, like it, it happened in Atlantis, uh, with the flood, right?
So it happened during the flood, it happened in Atlantis and the flood, it happened in Rome, whatever.
But when we're talking about like something that changed, whether it's literal or metaphorical, right?
Because I've always said when we do these spaces, right, this is a, this is a, a truth that is true either literally or metaphorically or both, right?
Because it keeps popping up.
So it's meaningful.
Um, so if we look at this as purely metaphorical, if we want to say, okay, uh, we're never going to know, we can't say this is actually a simulation.
The simulation is a metaphor.
The reality overlay is a metaphor for human societies or the power of the mind, right?
Um, Phil K.
Dick said we had parallel universes and at any given time, the dominant themes that were expressed in our society were based on what the majority of people believed.
So that's how you transition from one layer of the onion and the reality overlay to the other was by the, uh, a transition in the beliefs of the individuals, um, or human beings at that time.
Right.
So like culture through a science fiction lens, um, culture, like magnified through a science fiction lens so that it would change reality itself, like a Mandela effect.
So like by changing the culture, um, you would have a Mandela effect, which, which would lead to a different, um, a different type of reality.
And he, he believed that he was born in a world where the Nazis had won world war two.
That was one of his things.
I'm not saying he did.
I'm not saying he was, I'm saying he believed that.
And that he only, uh, showed up here after he, uh, got zonked out on, um, dental anesthetic in 1974.
Um, what we look at that when we talk about like the simulation reality overlay, how would it work?
Right.
So if it's strictly metaphorical.
If it's strictly a metaphor for genetics, if it's strictly a metaphor for the three types of individuals that Gnosticism talks about, right?
Quote Gnosticism that the early church talked about, that, that the people who had that belief talked about, whatever you, whatever you want to call them.
Right.
They said that there are three types of individuals.
They said that there are, uh, purely material human beings.
There are psychic human beings and there are spiritual human beings, right?
What they call them pneumatics, which doesn't sound too good for modern, for the modern era, I think.
But it means, you know, the air, right?
Um, there were three types of people inhabiting the same bodies.
Okay.
And so this is what ancient people believed.
And this is, this is something that is kind of taboo to talk about now.
Some, some of us believe it.
Right.
But like, it definitely goes against the universalist, um, culture that we have now, the, the universalist presuppositions.
So if you ask an ancient Gnostic, we'll call them Gnostics because that's what people like to call them.
Right.
If you ask them, they would say that, uh, a certain percentage of people were purely material, purely material.
I think they would have said much higher than 40%, but if they were in the center of the Roman empire, which is where they were, where that, you know, it's higher than 40% of people have that gene in, in, in Rome.
Right.
It's 40% of people on earth have that genetic mutation.
It's higher than 40% of people in that area.
So it would have seemed like almost everyone, if they were located in that area geographically, which they were, uh, are the Hilux, the purely material people, um, who resist and deny the existence of anything beyond the material world and universe.
That was something like just those are the people that are in charge of our, of our society.
Now they, they were in charge of Rome then as well, but they were, you know, they were well-represented in all levels of society and, uh, those that's, that's a highlight.
So we now have a genetic marker for Hilux, right?
So we now have a, a genetic marker for Hilux and psychics, uh, what the, um, ancient Gnostics talk about, right?
We, if, if this research is accurate, um, if it proves to be true, then you could say that that mutation found on the chromosome seven.
Um, is responsible for the existence of purely material human beings, people with no psychic ability and that people who do not have that mutation, um, have psychic ability as the result of, um, as a result of, uh, these retro, some sort of transfected retrovirus.
Um, what Philip K. Dick would call the divine invasion that happened at some point in history.
And then the question at that point, well, how, how do we identify the spiritual individuals, right?
My argument would be, and I know I'm going off on a tangent with this one.
My argument would be that to identify the pneumatics, the spiritual individuals, we'd be looking at people who, who did not, who have not lived their life with complete amnesia.
Right.
So when we talk about these topics and themes, like there are people that this is like complete science fiction too.
There are people who like think it's, these are interesting ideas, but there are also people who've always sort of held these opinions, even though they never really knew why.
So simulation theory supposedly began like 2001.
Okay.
But I can tell you, like I was in the nineties and that people believed that there, right.
And we can, we can trace it back to, you know, 1974, Philip K. Dick and his, some of his work before that.
And I bet you, if we looked into it, we'd find that, you know, there was no intervening period where it wasn't in the popular consciousness.
That there wasn't a period between like the Manichaeanism and, and Catharism and Vogelmullism.
Like there was a period, there are places where it wasn't in people's minds.
Right.
But it's always been part of human culture and, and human understanding.
So I think that people who naturally sort of have an understanding about how the world works and have a sense of mission or purpose.
I think that those individuals are your prime suspects for your pneumatics of the, of the, um, the three types of human beings.
So anyways, um, that's to make a long, I just fuck, I ran over.
God damn it.
Sorry.
I shouldn't say that.
I'm from Massachusetts and we say this stuff all the time.
And even after I, um, had a religious awakening, um, after I had my born again experience, uh, in 93, like even since then, you know, you just, you're around it all the time.
So saying God damn it and take them, taking the Lord's name in vain.
It's just sort of part of the culture here.
It's, um, it's something I work on and I do better some years than others.
Uh, so I don't mean to offend anyone who's listening who has a, you know, strong religious beliefs.
Uh, but I did go over by half an hour.
So to tie it all together, um, the psychic gene is not a psychic gene.
Um, nor is it a, uh, uh, a gene that keeps people from being psychic.
It's, um, it's a sequence.
It's a genetic mutation that suppresses the expression of endogenous, um, retroviruses recently acquired in the human population.
And, uh, therefore psychic ability is an external, um, or was external to human beings at one point.
Um, and, um, we gained it through exposure to these retroviruses, some sort of Adam and Eve virus, some sort of Sophia virus.
You can call it what you will, right?
Sophia was Eve.
It's just the same.
It's a retelling of the same story from a different perspective.
Um, and that's, you know, everything that Dean Radden and the noetic science people, um, the story they wanted to tell about what they discovered is wrong.
Um, and they're very intelligent people, but sometimes even very intelligent people can't see what's obvious right in front of their face.
So I don't know if they ever looked into what the actual function of the genes was, um, from like a non-psychic perspective.
And, and I don't know if they know that the function of that, that genetic mutation is to suppress the expression of endogenous retroviruses.
Um, if they, if they don't know that, then it's purely a confirmation bias thing when they went off in their tangent and Catholicism and the Inquisition and sort of stopped the spread of this information by, by taking that, that tact, um, tract, whatever.
Um, but if they did know, then they were like, if they understood what the gene did and they created this fake storyline around it, that, that would be pretty bad.
Like that would be, um, propaganda, right?
Uh, so I hope that's not the case, but, um, everything they had to say about it is wrong.
Um, but it, the, the research itself, the discovery, that's the word I'm looking for, is monumental.
It's like a smoking gun that explains everything.
Um, it ties, um, in alternative thought and clairvoyant movements, in esoteric Christianity, esoteric Buddhism, in everything we couldn't reconcile together in history.
It, it, it ties it together like very, very well.
And, um, the information about the location of this mutation, right?
It's a real mutation, like I said, it's been studied by geneticists, um, for those, uh, you know, uh, for the, um, what function it holds.
Um, obviously those individuals are not studying psychic abilities.
Um, the, um, the fact that it is located primarily in the former territory of the Roman empire, that information comes from 23andMe, where they were able to do genetic research in the database there.
So, uh, that information is about as accurate as you're going to get.
Like, so that part, I don't think a reasonable person, uh, unless you don't believe in the, in genetics, um, then that part of it, the fact that this genetic mutation is, is more common, is, is found primarily, primarily in the former Roman empire.
I mean, it's more common, the closer one gets to Rome, showing that it, it seemed to originate from that, from that geographic location.
Um, and the implications that that would have for culture and society, um, because of the, like I said, the introgression of the trait, right?
And how it would affect everything else.
Like the lack of foresight, the lack of a belief in anything but the material universe, like that would shape culture, um, that would shape science, right?
That would shape, shape academics, um, that would lead us to where we are right now, where we have a world full of people who believe there's more than what we can directly perceive.
Being governed by a minority of people who believe that the only thing that's real is what we can perceive and quantify and measure.
That's all explained by that, um, by that discovery of this genetic mutation.
So this is, it's, it's huge.
It's absolutely huge.
And the ramification, like, you know, when you get into the, like I said, the metaphorical, um, the possible metaphorical explanation for what these, these, uh, these, uh, intuitives,
these dreamers, these, even if, even if we say that, um, you know, the, the simulation isn't a, is a real, it's just a metaphor.
Like all of that can be explained from, from this one discovery.
So it's really huge.
And they, they tanked the whole thing.
Now, you know, I really, I reached out to a bunch of people and, you know, ask them to come and listen.
Now, I don't know what tremendous number of people on, on X, right.
But of all my, um, of all the, um, the spaces I've run that this one is, and everyone here is wonderful.
Everyone is, Stephanie, thank you.
And LH, thank you.
And, um, I don't think you're on this page, but I appreciate you listening.
Send in.
Thank you, Melissa.
You're, you're always here.
It's amazing.
Right.
Like you guys are great.
Um, but this, this is by far, right.
Like if this is, if this is true, what Dean Radden said was true.
Um, this is by far the biggest discovery of, of our lifetime.
And, uh, you know, I advertise and advertise, right.
And it just, it, to me, the lack of interest is interesting.
The same way that like trying to explain it, you know, when I tried to explain to some very
intelligent people, I expected them to immediately get what it meant.
Right.
That the, the gene suppresses the function of, of, of transfected retroviruses.
They didn't get it.
So I think it's interesting that this is a subject that, that some people seem to have
difficulty thinking about.
Um, whereas they intellectually, they would have no difficulty at all.
This is not like rocket science, but the idea itself is something about it, that it just
isn't easy for some people to think about beyond.
I think that 40%, um, although I'm sure that they would absolutely be unable to process this
information.
Um, there are some things I think we're just not supposed to think about.
Right.
But yeah, definitely the Christians didn't wipe out the psychic gene.
Uh, the, um, inquisition isn't responsible.
Right.
This would have to go back to Rome itself and the Roman empire, um, and would have to focus
more on the persecution of the cathars and, uh, obvious Indians and the bogomils, et cetera,
than it would like the hedge, which is during the, um, inquisition.
So, yeah, I mean, I, I think it's, it's completely amazing.
It's the Roman empire is that gene is that mutation.
It's not, it's not a geographic area.
It's not a religion.
It's not a, it's not a series of cultures and societies.
It's if, if what they're saying is true, that's, that's it.
Um, and, and everything that traces from it.
So I know I'm just repeating myself, but it's because I can't think of a better way to articulate
what I'm saying.
So thank you all for coming and listening to my rambling.
I wish that more people had been here.
I wish that people, Lou had been here to ask questions.
Cause I asked him, I said, can you, can you come and keep me on like the straight path?
Just, you know, ask questions when I'm not making any sense, when I'm rambling.
Um, cause I know this is going to be a difficult thing for me to talk about, to express, to articulate,
cause I don't never articulated it before in conversation.
And no one's ever articulated this particular, uh, argument before.
This is the world first here in, uh, this space.
It is a, a world first, uh, the first time anyone has ever talked about this particular
topic.
Um, it doesn't make me anything special.
It just so happens that no one seemed to look into it because everyone wanted to get, you
know, everyone wanted to run away with like redheaded psychics and stuff like that.
Um, confirmation bias and confabulation, as opposed to looking into what the genes actually
did, but it's lost, right?
Um, five of us and maybe five more people.
And, um, it'll be like, as if this conversation never happened.
And, um, this tremendous, um, tremendous discovery will be swept under the rug.
And, um, when no one will know if there's an actual marker that proves that these, these
storylines, this narrative is true, whether it's literally true or metaphorically true, that
is the debate now, right?
But if this, this marker is what they say it is, then.
Um, oh, well, no, what is an actual, okay.
So all of a sudden, um, I started getting subtitles and my subtitles are, um, pretty, pretty inarticulate,
which is how I always imagine I sound.
So I'm glad that, um, I'm glad that X is confirming that I sound pretty inarticulate.
All right, guys, I'm tired.
I'm going to go.
I appreciate everyone.
Um, I will be back, uh, at least four or five times over the next couple of months to do
more spaces.
Um, perhaps people will be more interested in those spaces.
I could, um, I could do something about, like, um, Tupacabra wrestling, um, Lou Elizondo and
pump up the numbers, get three or 400 people to come in and listen to, uh, listen to me describe
the wrestling moves that they would, um, they would use on each other as opposed to, you know,
talking about a, an earth-shaking, simulation-shaking, uh, historically unprecedented discovery, which
isn't going to get much attention at all.
All right.
Um, thank you all again, Melissa, Stephanie, uh, Sinan.
Thank you very much for showing up.
LH, uh, thank you for showing up and listening and whoever is out there that I can't see because
X will lock my screen.
Um, hopefully I'll see you next time, maybe next Saturday.
All right.